why would you bring that PJ this is like
go out on every day of my life with
corporate and that's exactly what we do
before the Sears my friend a friend of
mine when he just maybe three times a
year he just he just texts me a picture
from that shoe of me some some corporate
photoshoot that was quite serious went
on before I came into the recording
studio so anyway the the crazy part
about this you know one of the craziest
parts about this thing is like Brian and
I you know it always starts with just me
and Brian in the room and then we slowly
over the years add more and more people
and you know when when we were first
coming up with these characters we had
an idea of what like they might sound
like or whatever but it's not until you
hear actors come in and and do their
thing and an audition and stuff like and
and every once while you're like oh
that's the one that's totally what's in
my head that I couldn't explain so we
have another little treat for you which
is oh these three guys when in their
early audition days we we kind of put
him through the ringer and you know they
came in individually to do their
auditions and stuff and and we had a few
picks of like oh these these are a
couple potential people and then we so
we brought everyone in to kind of record
together to kind of see how the
chemistry would work and these guys had
amazing chemistry no no surprise there
but we're actually gonna play you
it's just audio but it's the it's their
very first the audition they did
together so not the very very first one
but the first one where the three of
them actually recorded together which
we've never heard this episode - I
believe yeah and this was by the way
this was PJ's idea very good idea Thank
You PJ those from episode 2 so you'll
hear from the
else's here a bunch of other stuff that
we had written I think in the episode
that later got cut or moved around or
changed and you'll hear a lot of PJ
improvising so we can roll that so what
do you think best seats in the house huh
well this is unbelievable right right I
mean do I know how to treat my friends
or what bowling yeah I told you you have
to stop bringing your crazy fan girls in
here before the matches you need to stop
flirting and start focusing you want to
win this match or not hey you know I do
well they get her out of here come on
Marco all right look I kind of promised
her she could stay but I'm telling you
look like she's not like the others okay
I got a good like a good feeling there's
just something I don't know it's like
something special about it
wait a second hey come over here I want
you to meet my brother oh this is Mac oh
yeah
really hey no don't get up I wouldn't
want you to strain your friendly muscle
right before a match wait what'd you say
your name was
I didn't it's Cora do you know who that
is
yeah her name's Cora cuz I just told you
that where'd you say you met her
I know toss a quarter sneaking around
backstage why do you care so much all of
a sudden because that girl is the avatar
no way
you should really pick up a newspaper
sometime see yes yes I told you she was
special
hey how you doing again I'm sorry I
didn't realize you what you I'm sorry
you know back say jewelry back say to
you oh here oh this is a total honor to
meet you because I'm like a really big
like a major but you can stop shaking my
hand oh right sorry I didn't want to
shake your hand that long I did want to
shake your hand could you keep your
voice down just I'm not exactly supposed
to be here so oh you got it totally hey
you know what I'm just gonna be asking
secret stuff that's actually kind of
boss specialty yes let's get ready for
the match now
I'm focused I'm looking at her focus
that was like the legend of bolon I know
we always would joke because PJ likes to
do improvising it's always hilarious but
we said we only have 22 minutes per
episode PJ can we can we do one yeah
you generally come out of 30 minutes and
then chop from there chopping off it
sounds like the show I think I thought I
don't know what I thought like that I
would be like it doesn't sound like me
even though you know what really came
into clarity for me is why you hired the
three of us no no I thought it was cool
man I love the chemistry actually yeah
awesome
so we also asked these guys to since
this is our kind of farewell con Oh to
prepare you know just any any words they
want to say or anything take this
opportunity individually to kind of talk
about their experience so Janet take it
away yeah I think when we found out that
we were gonna have a little bit of time
to talk to you guys I think we all froze
and we didn't really know how to even
put into words what this experience has
been like and and I don't have anything
prepared because I didn't want to just
like what am I going to read some
statement I'm gonna read this is this is
you know I've talked about this in a
couple of interviews before but it
really does kind of cement what my
experience has been like which is that
when I got the when I got the role Sara
Noonan the amazing Sara Noonan at
Nickelodeon who had you know kind of
shepherded us through the audition
process I ran into her at Nickelodeon
and she and the show was about to
premiere and she said are you ready for
your life to change and I was like I
mean
my first job I mean I mean I do live in
LA and I like I work you know and and
she was like cheap seriously like
grabbed my arm she was like I'm not
kidding this will change your life and
and it has and and having the
opportunity to watch the episodes when
we come to these cons with you guys
flushes it out in such a profound way
and it's always really hard for me to
come back on stage after we've watched
an episode because I get really
emotional most of you know this already
yes I get really really emotional
watching the show and and if I if I
haven't said it a thousand times maybe
this will be the thousands I have never
worked on anything better than this show
I can't imagine I can't imagine ever
working on anything better than the show
I am so so honored to be a part of it I
don't know how it happened I think we
just went through the whole casting
process but I don't know how I got so
lucky I'm not a day goes by that I don't
feel incredibly gifted and blessed to be
a part of this amazing cast in this
extraordinary show and I to me this is
not the end in any way you know I
learned from you guys taught me that you
guys taught me that this isn't our last
con I'm gonna continue to do cons
because I love interacting with you guys
but also you know when I have the good
fortune to come out and and hang with
you guys I see so many of you just
passionately carrying the torch of and
that whole crew and I believe in this
show the way I believe in Avatar and I
know that the show is gonna exist
forever because it's just that god damn
good
sorry I cursed Nickelodeon haha you just
couldn't control yourself the spirit
took me Thank You Janet Thank You Jen I
guess it's my turn now yes for me this
has just been a tremendous experience
had no idea what I was getting into when
I went into that audition that you just
heard so it's been it's been quite a
it's been quite an experience I've gone
from hey bud Bundy - hey Mack oh so it's
very cool I mean as the kids come up
they're like Marco Marco Marco the young
people and then the parents were like
hey bud Bundy
so it's a it's a two-for-one but I'm
just so glad to be a part of this show
really I had a tremendous time and it
will continue on I believe for a long
time you guys will be watching it and
like Janet said will we doing
conventions and I'm sure we'll see you
around and I just so appreciate all the
love like on Twitter and Facebook and
and and Instagram and so much love from
all of you guys and the support thank
you thank you thank you and thank you
Brian and Mike for very strong very
strong general cry for thank you I love
you you know I guess first and foremost
it's like thank you guys I mean Mike and
Brian for for giving us this incredible
gift of us actors you know not only are
we a part of this like epic you know I
think historic show that will stand the
test of time and it's this tetralogy
that we sort of left that's Greek for
for but the other thing is is the gift
you know a lot of jobs you go on you you
know it's for six months or for how long
but I got I got to go home for five
years to hang out with my friends you
know that was that was an incredible
gift that we became so close and I think
we'll be friends forever I'm so I didn't
say that before you got me forever guys
that projects you guys you know me
forever a lot of shows you don't stay
friends for a long time I mean your
projects you leave and then that's you
know your family while you're doing it
and then it's over but I do feel like no
absolutely have come to my house yeah
I've seen where you shower it's amazing
okay sorry missed that part yeah and the
other thing is I truly believe I mean
from the cons we've gone to and here I
really believe we have the best fans of
any show amazing and I sort of like I
value you every time you that I I want
honored yeah and I'm sorry hope you feel
like I'm stepping on you but I I didn't
want to just acknowledge as much as we
could even in the the video that you saw
I brought so much like I brought as much
kind of fan art and stuff as I could for
the video we used a bunch of it I have
my little core at all that someone gave
me she was she was in a deleted scene
where PJ was manipulating her and it was
causing me to do things anyway you guys
have your you're out there making you
know these amazing cosplay costumes your
your your drawing beautiful fan art and
and I know Mike and Brian - are are so
impressed by the stuff that you guys are
creating and and that's really inspiring
I think it's inspiring for us to see you
guys get inspired and creating all this
amazing stuff so there's this kind of
great give and take that happens and and
it feels like you guys are very much a
part of this experience too so thank you
so so glad for you yes thank you fans
yeah but the final thing I want to say
that sort of makes all of this okay that
it's ending i with the families we have
two creators over there with like I
think some of the best creative minds
that are alive right now truly and you
know we're sort of we're on this earth
and we're given a finite period of time
to exist so that's true this show is
coming to an end but what I am so overly
overly overly excited about is Oh Polly
I can't wait for for the next project
that is hiding like deep dark crevices
of their brain
no matter what venue if it's a cartoon
it's live at whatever it is like we're
we're so lucky a that we got to be a
part of this and you guys got to watch
it but like I think the world is gonna
be so lucky to see what's gonna come
next
from those two guys heads coming down
the road side yeah back at you PJ 1980s
mark turtlenecks 1980s motorized well
thank you so much guys that those were
very heartfelt words and and we cherish
all of them and yeah it's been awesome
we're just get so we're so lucky that we
get such talented artists and producers
and actors and directors to just join in
with us on this crazy thing I mean
there's no way we could do this alone
and it doesn't all come from us it's
it's a huge huge effort from a lot of
people but it's great when the people
care about the work as much as we do and
they're so talented and generous with
their gifts know there's some actors you
might come in do their part and they're
done you know and that's it but you guys
are like you are part of the Avatar
family now and yeah stuck with us and
you're great you guys are such great
ambassadors for this show and and we've
seen you with the fans and seen their
reaction to you guys and they know how
much you care and and we appreciate that
well we got a few minutes left I
prepared some artwork to show you guys
since book four was such a leap forward
in time virtually every character had to
have their design updated there's a lot
of design it was fun to do but it was
really taxing but one of the first
characters is kuvira so we knew that you
know while we were writing book three we
came up with the idea that kuvira was
going to be the the main antagonist and
villian in book four so we had this idea
to weave her throughout because we knew
she was going to come from from south
foo so we wanted to weave her throughout
the season so that this was
first concept I did of her before we
even saw her in book three I didn't
really know quite what her you know
military garb would look like but this
is just this this concept so I did this
we had it hanging on the the writers
room wall for a little while but then
the first time we saw her she was one of
the dancers in su beifong gymnasium so
Angie and I did this kind of quick
design of her and you can see a little
change she got the little like influence
from Sue's hair in the little bangs
hanging down the side and then we knew
that she would be like the captain of
Sue's security so we put her in the kind
of Zhou food security uniform that
helmet never really fit her head I don't
know why her eyebrows were too dominant
and yeah it's a tiny little thing but I
did the storyboard of the little scene
where you know she I spelled her name
wrong
we better I think it's printing like
that in the art book I don't think we
good to know
I probably drew this much like the way I
put this panel together which was at
about 5:30 in the morning only an
all-nighter so there you go I'm human
too so it was funny seeing not until it
was like all animated and I heard yeah
you know kuvira's voiced by the
wonderfully talented Zelda Williams and
I
I heard the read and I was like it seems
like she's hitting on and so people
picked up on that that's not what was
intended but I didn't mind the mislead
so this was my first concept I knew she
was going to be this total kick-ass
metal bender so I wanted her to have
this kind of segmented metal armor but I
was a little worried this looked a
little too superhero II and it was I
knew this was going to be a complicated
design for the animators so I was trying
to simplify it so tried streamlining the
metal armor a little bit I like the
longer coat
which is sort of a like short in the
front long in the back sort of the
Avatar motif that have gone back to a
lot but the animators in Korea almost
killed me for the tassels that the earth
Queen had so the the long the long braid
had to go because it would be too hard
to animate it with since her costume was
so complex anyway that thing would be
flapping around and driving animators
crazy also I guess Katniss has some kind
of like that side to get rid of it so
then she got the bun I also thought if
she was gonna be this super serious
military leader that she probably
wouldn't have hair dangling around
anyway she should have a more refined
look so I did this this version of the
costume which is getting pretty close to
what ended up being in the show and then
Ryu helped me kind of refine some things
like the shoulder pads it's always it's
all you can draw like big bulky shoulder
pads but then figuring out how they move
is a whole other matter but he helped me
with that and then tapering the the the
metal plates in the back which I think
it ended up being one of the coolest
parts I heard design so yeah this was
the finished cleanup that I did and oh
no that was the rough this is the
cleanup I mean you got the color there
and then so once I had this outfit it
kind of helps set the look for her army
and we had to figure out all the like
because she pulls metal from different
parts of her armor so did these little
this little breakdown for the animators
how that all works and Ryu again like
once we had that rough design he was
doing a lot of storyboards with her and
those storyboards of his became sort of
the like the template for how she should
look and her attitude and body language
Ryu is so good at like expressions and
poses so we used a lot of these as the
basis for her expression sheets these
are used storyboards from from 401 and
man I love that introduction of her it's
just so fun and she's just so heartless
about the whole thing yeah I didn't even
raise her pulse so as you can see there
we really you and I did these expression
sheets based on his storyboards I sort
of took his boards and cleaned him up
and these were really fun to do still a
really complex model for the animators
to draw she's got a lot going on so
again like I said that her outfit sort
of set the look and I had to figure out
all these different military ranks so
you know the next in command is her is
her fiance avatar junior who's a total
wet noodle and yeah so I came up with
this whole like patch system with these
Chevron's to denote ranks and I had this
this like dream I didn't get time to
pull it together but I wanted to come
out on stage dressed like this because
I've totally got the the hair nerdy
glasses I even do some stunts
grunts and stuff for him but anyway so
then we blow him you've got like
sergeant and you'll see these little
minor details but it's like the trim on
the coat and the double trim on the
cuffs and the three bar Chevron and then
Bolin is like corporal level you'll
notice Eric's corporal level is like
slightly different were you guys going
on there thank you and and then like the
metal benders he's kind of scary
stormtrooper people and it was fun doing
the kind of World War two style helmet
but with like a samurai influence and
then like privates totally some GI Joe
flashbacks coming and then this design
the the mecha pilots those cool like
streamlined mecha-suits you get to see
these pilots which Rakeem de santos did
that main design and then we have you'll
see these people they were the ones that
threw the pie
I the pies that Prince Wu they're not
actually conscripted you know like
they're not in the army but these are
just like the supporters you know they
buy into all the propaganda and they're
usually they they hand out a lot of
pamphlets yeah usually teenagers you
know and positive in applies very
forcefully Chris Christine be on did
this amazing design of kuvira's train
these are these maglev trains you know
you remember Varrick talking about
magnets in book three this is kind of
what he was talking about these
high-speed like bullet trains so it was
really fun taking the art deco vibe of
zafu and then making a more military
version of it but Christine is just such
an amazing prop designer this was a
really cool one and and then Joaquim is
such a he's such a master of like robots
and so he he just banged out this
incredible concept for these streamlined
mech suits and originally they were
meant we meant them to be just human
sized you know just a little bit bigger
but all the storyboard artist drew them
really tall and we just it I mean all of
them did and they did it so much that we
had to just scale them up once we got to
the animation so so that's why Keens
original concept and then Christine
beyond took him it's ok didn't sort of
flush it out and we figured out all the
weapons and functions it would have what
game would be like hey Brooke could be
I'm meeting I'd come in and be like can
it do this can it can its legs extend
sure okay and then we'd like add it to
the list of all the things but then
those things had to be designed so then
Christine this full turnaround kind of
extrapolating Joaquin's design and then
these two had ranks so you see this is
like the private level and they also
have the little chevron thing on the arm
the color coded differently so this is
kind of the Platinum look and then the
green one for the Corporal and then the
black one is the sergeant with the three
Chevron so another big thing it was
really fun
the wing the wing suits and I was really
excited about this I was talking about
this in an interview earlier but like
kind of modernizing the air band you
know the air nation and we never got to
say it in the show but one thing about
these suits the idea is I'm just gonna
tell you guys no Asami designed these so
these are like future Industries special
you know like special cutting edge
fabrics and all this stuff so she
wouldn't have wanted to be one of the
test pilots but you know so I was on a
trip back to see a friend in Kentucky
and I had my iPad and I just was
doodling because you know we were
getting to that point in the storyboards
where we had to know how do these things
work or do they look like so you know
this one you can see it's kind of using
Chi as like the model you can see it's
kind of baggy I was trying to figure out
what these folded up wings would would
be like and still trying to hang on to
the you know the original Aaron Aaron
nation costume but I didn't really I
kept showing some ideas like how like
the baggy look I think was a good note
so we went naked yeah this is so
streamlined you can't even sew Angie
Angie or Christy did this so you know we
had to update all that the ragtag kind
of Bad News Bears air nation people so I
don't remember I talked about three
years of you know eating vegetarian and
working out every day he's trimmed down
looking good and so this so I took that
kind of concept from my iPad sketch and
I started working you know on top of
this model sheet but again it was
looking a little baggy but so I started
figuring out what it would look like
when he was flying and from there it all
came together and so I used opal as the
main the main wine
and just you know it's a bit it's
definitely a big cheat but this sort of
like folding wings system and it just
kind of tucks under you know it sort of
wraps under and then it kept it out of
the way and I really like
this streamlined look so I did this
design and then Christie did these
awesome expressions of opal I just want
to note I had like I've seen people
commenting about how Cora and opals hair
looks really similar you can see on the
model sheet it is quite different but
once once the animators drew it it kind
of looks the same and then once it gets
colored oh well I've I've given you guys
so that's why I like hair silhouettes
eventually some are gonna look the same
but I'm just I'm so stoked on how this
came out I just really I love the color
scheme and and I love seeing like when
Kai and opal show up in these new
outfits I'm just like yeah and then
Christy put together this cool not exact
yura tight thing because I know people
like too bad they like to hate on me for
heights which believe me there'll be
some more you can hate on me in a minute
but it was cool seeing all the
airbenders in in their new outfits so
that would come to Cora wear has so many
so many outfit changes I gotta fly
through these so this is her stock you
know just like book to model and then
one way easiest way to show someone
growing up in animation because we can't
do really subtle things is she got
taller so sorry nate is or is even
taller now and and somehow her vision
grew up to even though that was from
three years ago her vision grew taller
too so the dark avatar scary vision
update that and then this is the kind of
in-between stage you saw that scene so
anytime you guys see something like that
it has to be designed it's not just like
someone on a set where they can just
like take their hair down and you know
like we have to do the design and like I
like that version there's something cool
about the blue against the green and
then she cuts her hair and it's gets the
little league Muay Thai armbands and I
really love this costume
Chris Christy and I worked on this one
together and then she gets beat up
but again we have to design that stuff
like whenever there's battle damage I
really love this design Angie did this
variation with the parka and I wish we
saw it more that she was wearing this
like when she went up to the northern
portal and then you've seen it in the
trailer but it hasn't shown up the
episodes yet but I did the her final
kind of like Korra the avatar look and I
really love this one and if I find the
link I want to send you guys these boots
they're real and they're vegan so I can
recommend them for your cosplay but yeah
I wanted like her kind of classic look I
always loved the long sleeves and but
with like a slight bit more of a
superhero vibe she's kind of like so so
there you go there's that stuff and then
real quick the video game is coming out
this month October 21st activision so
you can check it out on these different
platforms from from activision and
platinum games they did such a great job
i hope you guys enjoy it this is the
poster that i did that's available at
the Dark Horse booth Mike and I and
Janet are doing a signing tomorrow from
11:00 to 1:00 they're gonna be giving
out tickets for that in the morning so
ticketed signing so try to get that but
I think you can get a poster all weekend
Geof Darrow the legendary artist comic
book artist did this and Dave Stewart
legendary colorist colored this they're
gonna raffle some of these and then
otherwise they're gonna have limited
edition prints on Omnicom and then it's
not over yet quiet down appreciate that
I just want to take a quick moment you
know Mike and I just this is a really
big deal for us you know it's been it's
been 12 years since we came up with this
whole Avatar universe together and
we I'll just like Avatar means so many
different things to so many different
people but for to me when I think of it
when I think of it the creation of it I
just think of me and Mike sitting at my
computer and my this little rented house
in Burbank and we would just share the
keyboard we would take turns and just
over a series of two weeks we cracked
open this whole universe together and
and it's 12 and a half years later and
it's just blossomed into something so
huge and it's such a part of it's such a
big part of our lives and so many people
all over the world and these these
characters are real to us you know not
in a delusional way in an emotional way
you know they're they really mean a lot
to me and I know it's Mike as well so at
4 a.m. I drew this little thing for you
guys and and we just want to say thanks
thanks guys until that and now I'm
crying thanks a lot
and Janet cranks everybody